the energy union is at the top of the
agenda of the next tte council EU
ministers will exchange views on a
strategic framework proposed by the
commission the aim is giving consumers
secure sustainable competitive and
affordable energy while addressing the
existing challenges in the sector it
also seeks to contribute to attaining
the 20 30 goals on climate and energy in
June 2014 the european council
established a strategic agenda for the
union in times of change with energy and
climate policies being one of its five
building blocks the outcome of the
debate will be forwarded to the
President of the European Council ahead
of the March meeting of EU leaders
ministers will also hold a policy debate
on the developments and priorities for
energy infrastructure the debate will
focus on key measures to further promote
the implementation of an interconnected
cross-border energy market including
ending the energy isolation of member
states ways of improving investment for
the energy sector will also be discussed
as well as regional cooperation in order
to achieve the ten percent minimum
target of electricity interconnections
by 2020 the outcome of the debate will
figure in the Presidency's report on
Europe 2020 strategy